Tommy? Yes Tommy. There's
another baby coming Billy!
Wanda push! Push!
[Screaming]
Welcome back everyone hopefully you've
had a chance to see Wandavision episode
three this is going to be my deeper video
on the new x-men mutant characters they
just introduced in the house of m alternate
reality that they're playing out on the show
and what this means for marvel phase 4 and
x-men mutant characters in the mcu going forward
if you're brand new to the channel i'm doing
videos for all the new Wandavision episodes the
other marvel disney plus series that are coming up
this year like falcon and winter soldier be sure
to subscribe to get all those we're also doing a
disney plus giveaway for memberships all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and leave all
your theories about what they're going to do with
the wiccan and speed characters going forward
in future marvel projects careful for spoilers
for everything that's happened on Wandavision
so far if you haven't seen any of the episodes
but during Wandavision episode 3 scarlet witch
gives birth to her twin children from the comics
billy and tommy wicken and speed there are several
reasons why that's a huge deal Wandavision isn't
just meant to set up doctor strange 2 multiverse
of madness and spider-man 3 spider-verse but kevin
feige also confirmed recently that wandavision
is also meant to help set up the new marvel x-men
movies and mutants in the mcu through their house
of m storyline and some other stuff that'll become
more apparent in future episodes that includes
a lot of unannounced big projects like young
avengers that they haven't officially talked about
yet but that clearly seem like they're setting up
with all these different marvel disney plus series
in the younger teenage characters but mutants
overall are coming to the mcu and the marvel
movies in a number of different ways in twists so
Wandavision and the two new twins are just one of
those ways and i know a lot of you are asking is
scarlet witch a mutant in the mcu does that make
quicksilver a mutant because technically they'd be
the first mutants in the mcu not wiccan and speed
marvel's been back and forth on that previously
they haven't said anything about it because of
the fox rights situation with the term mutant
they couldn't use the term while fox still had
the rights to the x-men characters now they can
do whatever they want to they can call anybody a
mutant that they want to but back when they still
had that rights issue there was some canonical
tie-in material that presented scarlet witch
as a mutant or quicksilver as well technically
because of both twins as mutants in the mcu saying
that the mind stone merely unlocked their latent
abilities they'll get into that in future episodes
too like we just got the big quick silver name
drop during episode 3. finally mention quicksilver
again in the mcu haven't talked about pietro
since avengers age of ultron i had a brother
his name was pedro he was killed by ultron wasn't
he i know a lot of you are hoping to see him show
up on the series a lot of people expecting a big
twist hoping that evan peters quicksilver from
the fox x-men movies actually shows up instead
we'll continue to see more easter eggs for that
stuff so we'll just wait and see what kind of big
wtf moments they reveal with quicksilver stuff
but if you're not a big comic book reader
they've confirmed that the Wandavision series
is adapting a few major comic books and then just
borrowing smaller bits from a bunch of others
the two major ones and this was confirmed by
paul bettany recently are x-men house of m
pretty obvious there in tom king's vision run
also pretty obvious from the plot so far you
probably spotted most of those easter eggs pretty
early on but during the house of m's scarlet witch
story line she gets sick with grief and mentally
unstable creates this alternate reality with her
powers where she can escape her problems just
like the hydra soap commercial calgon take me
away to the house of m where mutants are in the
majority and regular people are in the minority
and during the tom king vision run vision on
his own separately just moves into the suburbs
and creates a family of androids for himself
literally builds himself a family attempting to
live a normal 1950s looking life like you saw in
the first couple of episodes as you would expect
neither one of those story lines ends well for
anyone then there are a lot of easter eggs in
the series for a number of smaller comics like
vision and scarlet witch's miniseries where she
gave birth to their twins for the first time and
there'll be a lot of other comic books that they
reference in future episodes i'll point out as we
go along but those are just the biggest ones the
whole thing about scarlet witch's children wiccan
and speed though is that in the comics originally
they weren't real they were revealed to be soul
shards of mephisto and he reabsorbed them into his
body because vision was an android he couldn't
technically have children as you would expect
it was just one of the many occasions that
they use to drive scarlet witch crazy where
she unleashes her power she loses control of her
powers and becomes a bit of a villain briefly kind
of like you saw her go all thanos on monica rambo
during episode 3. you took everything from me but
also i don't even know who you are the versions
of wiccan and speed that most people know from the
comics from the young avengers comics are actually
revealed as reincarnations of scarlet witch's
original children the ones that wound up being
soul shards and that was marvel's way of sort of
combining the classic story with the modern story
because they introduced wiccan and speed during
the young avengers comics and then wanted to make
them twins and make them scarlet witch's children
so if mephisto originally reabsorbed them as soul
shards how could these ones be their children well
because they're reincarnations of the souls of
her original children don't worry the Wandavision
tv show will have a vastly simplified version
of billy and tommy's story lines but as we've
seen the last couple of episodes they have that
creepy chant for the children everything is for
those little boys and girls and also during the
first few episodes we've noticed that the strange
things that have manifested are really just
manifestations of scarlet witch's subconscious
that last scene from episode 3 is meant to clarify
that the reason that act of the harkness or agnes
whatever you want to call her is tiptoeing around
and she's so afraid upsetting scarlet witch
so much that she punts her out of the bubbled
alternate reality of westview just like she did to
monica rambo i know that a lot of questions about
what's going on with agnes there is a lot of other
stuff happening with that part of the storyline
i'll talk about in future episodes she's one of
the most important characters on the series but
based on the way the scarlet witch is controlling
everything and everyone forcing them to play out
her fantasy of these different sitcoms in decades
it's implied that she really wanted to have a
family with vision like the tom king vision run
get married have a house in the suburbs have
children just like a totally normal average
nuclear family i know people are thinking about
children of the adam nuclear family because that's
a big x-men story line as well too but when
everyone is creepily chanting for the children
despite the fact that there's no children anywhere
in the neighborhood until she gets pregnant
the reason why they're doing that is probably
because subconsciously she's using her god-tier
powers in this reality to make them do that like
she's thinking about having children she wants
to have children so that sort of manifests in all
the other townspeople they're also chanting about
doing things creating a good environment for
children then every once in a while you notice
that something happens there's like a big bang
or an explosion or something weird happens and it
shakes them out of her control and they realize
what's happening like wait a minute where am i
what's going on who are you what are you doing
here till she snaps them back and they go back
to whatever their normal personality is within
the different decades if there's any confusion
about that the townspeople in west view are real
people who are just trapped inside there like
they lived in west view before she came along
in early theory scarlet witch just went to this
suburban town selected it and maybe with the
help of someone else like agnes maybe mephisto
nightmare someone else she created this alternate
reality around it to do basically what the hydra
soap commercial was talking about the calgon
parody calgon take me away from my problems she
went to a fantasyland created a fantasyland where
she could avoid all her real mcu world problems so
her getting pregnant giving birth within the span
of 30 minutes wouldn't be possible in the normal
mcu dimension but because she can alter reality
like comic book scarlet witch inside this place
like she's a god she essentially created her two
mutant children and they're fake just like the
originals in the comics here's the thing though
as we saw with monica rambo in episode 3 monica's
clothing her personality kind of changed along
with the rest of the towns when scarlet witch
subconsciously changed everything from the 1960s
to be in the 1970s and in color and when she gets
punted out back to the normal mcu universe she's
still wearing those 1970s clothes scarlet witch
created out of nothing the things that she created
out of nothing inside that alternate dimension
stuck so i think that's the little clue or teaser
marvel is giving us that both billy and tommy
wicked and speed will be able to continue
existing in the normal mcu once this fake
alternate tv reality crumbles just like the house
of m reality crumbled the first twin who's born
tommy is the speed character he has powers just
like quicksilver super speed as you would expect
billy the second twin is wiccan he has magic and
reality warping powers just like scarlet witch so
i know a lot of you have wondered if maybe it was
actually wiccan for instance inside her womb that
was making everything go crazy during the episode
because she didn't seem like she knew exactly what
was happening there were a couple reasons why
though scarlet witch seems like she's mentally
out to lunch about a lot of things during the
episodes like a lot of this is her drinking her
own kool-aid when clearly she knows what's going
on like when she kicks monica rambo out after she
starts talking about quicksilver and ultron she
knows exactly what's happening and where she is
like what are you doing here inside my fantasy get
the hell out of here but then in other scenes it
seems like she has no idea what's going on so i
think at various times because of her fluctuating
mental level of health her mental state she's
sort of drinking her own kool-aid and just living
out the lie letting herself believe the lie but
the answer to all the weird stuff i think is a
combination of both scarlet witch losing control
of her powers in combination with wiccans powers
in the womb starting to manifest so yes wiccan and
speed inside her womb were partially responsible
for some of the stuff that was going on the
joke about tommy speed is that he was born first
because he's got super speed so of course he'd
shoot out first we will see a lot more scenes
of the twins using their powers in future episodes
as they get older though one of the biggest sitcom
tropes is how they deal with children misbehaving
but because this is Wandavision it's a marvel show
it's about what happens and how the parents deal
when two super powered mutant children do bad
stuff or go off the rails but a lot of you've also
realized that the whole reason for this westview
alternate reality to play out so quickly through
each of the decades the accelerated timeline is
because as they say for the children like they
keep chanting during episode 2 it's all about
aging the children up super quickly so that they
can use them in future marvel phase 4 marvel phase
5 projects like the long rumored young avengers
series during marvel phase 4 there are already
or they will introduce the vast majority of the
entire original comic book young avengers team
so just like kevin feige said wanda vision will
help set up a lot of other stuff in addition to
x-men mutants doctor strange 2 spider-man 3 young
avengers is just one of the things on those lists
the other big connections Wandavision has
to setting up mutants and x-men stuff going
forward in the mcu is through the multiverse
plot that's a huge deal during marvel phase 4
just multiverse in general as a storytelling
trope so if it sounds like it's going to get
really confusing with a lot of the continuity and
blending a lot of the old fox movies with the new
mcu movies don't worry that's what characters
like deadpool are for for calling out a lot of
the inconsistencies these timelines so confusing
just cleaning up all the timelines so hopefully
that explains what's going on with wiccan and
speed's characters and how this relates to new
x-men mutant stuff happening in marvel phase four
marvel phase five my Wandavision episode 4 video
will post next friday but i'll probably be doing
some more bonus videos before then leave all your
requests or your big questions in the comments
below congratulations john john tadak you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Wandavision
video please email me on the about page of my
channel so i can get your contact details everyone
click here for my full Wandavision episode 3 video
and click here for that Wandavision
avengers endgame deleted post credits scene
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you in the next video!